we're about to watch some NFL gruesome
injuries and I have the man the legend
Brandon Marshall in the house to help me
dissect some of these talk about it from
a doctors and athlete's perspective
let's get started
[Applause]
this is a hand issue
Wilson and oh the middle finger of
Wilson are we making it worse as players
when we start grabbing these things and
yeah trying to make it work again I mean
it's not helping you want to right away
put a turn not a tourniquet splint on in
order to decrease the motion especially
with an injury like that mallet finger
what happens is you actually have a
fracture from the tendon that attaches
to the top of the finger that allows you
to move your finger this way so imagine
you lose that tendon the finger just
hangs you remember this one a couple
years ago yeah for sure take off to the
left get pulled down by
Logan Ryan
oh the leg is facing the other way this
mechanism here of having the other
player's knee fall directly onto his
ankle and see the change you know this
is a compound fracture because it's
poking out of his skin have you ever
seen on the field an injury this like
gruesome absolutely and also this play
right this play is a band play this is a
horse collar right so like grabbing a
guy by the back of his neck
but it's how they do it with their body
weight it's a very dangerous play we can
play hard and play rough but we should
also try to protect each other on the
field he's lucky actually it wasn't his
knee as well probably I wouldn't be
surprised if he broke both tibia and
fibula but there you could put Hardware
recovering a knee is tricky because now
you're talking about soft tissue damage
as opposed to bones bones heal well soft
tissue ligaments tendons those can be
tricky in some cases especially for an
athlete like that right it's another one
and there goes Alex Smith down at the
40-yard line Kareem action
he doesn't know
that Alex is injured
Alex Smith is down
here's the mechanism
leg got caught
oh jeez
oh my God okay so you could see again
loose bones yeah what's unique about
this fracture uh upon after reviewing it
is it's a spiral fracture which means
that there was like a torsional force on
the bone so it doesn't just break on one
line it kind of breaks on a diagonal
line going up the bone and that
obviously is a different level of
fracture because now it's creating a
sharp point that comes out through the
skin and becomes really problematic and
for Alex Smith this was even worse
because then he developed a bacterial
infection ended up with sepsis sepsis is
basically when the infection actually
enters from the wound into your blood
goes throughout the body and then that
bacteria causes all your blood vessels
to dilate and when your blood vessels
dilate your blood pressure drops so you
don't get enough circulation to your
brain your vital organs oh we actually
invited Alex Smith to the podcast Alex
Smith
come
[Applause]
on
[Music]
we'll look at it with the reversing what
exactly happened it's similar to oh he
had a legacy but it's similar to that
same horse crawler from Dak Prescott the
jump you know now we have different
rules for quarterbacks do you think the
rules have gone and the Pendulum has
swung a little bit too far in protecting
quarterbacks or do you think it's fair
too far like listen we got to make the
game safer I'm all for that protecting
guys but what I don't want to see is
what we saw a few times this year
defensive player running in the pocket
and literally just chest bump the
quarterback the quarterback stands up
shocked and get out the pocket throws it
away or throws a completion or throws a
touchdown it's tough It's a tough thing
it's a business but right now I don't
think it's all the way fear for the
defender oh this is college this was
nasty
setting up a screen
oh my God this is brutal this is this is
the knee injury that's right the ACL MCL
here see this is where I'm talking about
where on this exam there's tears there's
massive Global swelling you can't make a
diagnosis that's right you just know
something is torn that's right you need
to get images on it you need to get
images you need to go back on the replay
see what happened and then you could
make a an educated guess oh this is
terrible oh it's really problematic when
you see some of these injuries you know
a lot of times you just look at the the
player on the ground but there's so many
other people yeah it's like counting on
this person to get up and be healthy and
you're thinking about that as an athlete
yeah some of the first things you think
about is like oh can I play again
the back end for the Patriots here's
Murray
no slide
yeah you know what when you see a
non-contact injury yeah you
automatically think the worst yeah it's
like when a guy goes down and no one
touches them you're like oh this is bad
right there from the the footage I could
tell you it looks more ACL because he's
trying to move forward like his body's
trying to move forward but his cleat is
planted so his upper leg continues to
move but the lower leg is stuck so that
tells me the thing that keeps your knee
in place from Full extra Forward Motion
is the ACL is gone rolling left with the
grain and down
and this wasn't on purpose no by the
Bengals by any means no not at all it's
momentum when you see this as a doctor
you know seeing them in this state
fingers everything's stuck like that the
concern for me goes into a situation is
is there bleeding inside the brain is
this a seizure from such a bad injury
because all those things are very
possible with a hit like that that was
vicious and the fact that that happens
so often and then under reported under
recognized I understand from players
like I've had players ask me to clear
them for things and I understand that
they're coming from a good place but I
still don't know how to have that
conversation in a good way because it
feels like I'm keeping them from
something that they want success in but
I'm also looking after their health so I
don't I don't even know what the right
things to say is to pacify that
situation how do you feel as an athlete
have you ever had a concussion uh one
for me I mean just going off a tour it's
hard because I'm asked the one that I
had because it was my contract year it's
It's tricky because there's a lot of
emotion there's a lot of like business
business behind it but not even
businesses like it's everything like
when I said with Willis McGahey when
you're laying on the ground you know I
probably would have been thinking about
you know my mother my sister who had
just had a kid at 16. so a lot of times
not even just about you but with two uh
the older me wiser me mature in me again
it's like sit your ass down yeah right
because like there's this discussion
after he suffered a second one then
we're looking at you know this third one
that he's he actually reported it's like
will he play for the in the playoff game
is he going to come back and it's like
that doesn't matter right now to have
two three four in one year yeah now
you're looking at your career definitely
being over life I mean worry you know
there's personality changes that happen
with the concussion right especially in
the short term they get aggressive I see
in the sweetest high school kids that I
met them before the game sweetest kids
they get a concussion right yelling
screaming cursing out their trainers who
they have a great relationship with so
you see that on the sideline from one of
your teammates are you telling them sit
down what did I like to say what do you
like to say
sit your ass down yeah you said that
before oh absolutely especially with
concussions even you know at the height
of this discussion you know even in
boxing right someone gets knocked out
yeah me to everybody just like you feel
it yeah everybody feels that you know so
no I'm telling my brother you know to go
sit down you know it's not worth it for
sure
this one's hard uh and it's emotional
because you know he died on the field
right that's something most people don't
say that's accurate actually that's
right so obviously initially you see
contact chest contact but then you also
see his head hit the ground so it's hard
for me to know right out the outset
what's happening yeah but you know what
we do differently as Sports Med doctors
mechanism of injury like how an injury
happened sometimes gives us more info
than actually doing an exam knowing that
he became pulseless knowing that his
heart stopped abruptly and then seeing
that hit to the chest is the reason why
a lot of doctors jump to speculate that
this is that commercial Cordis condition
where in a very specific millisecond of
a moment during the electrical rhythm of
your heart you take a physical trauma to
the chest wall and your heart goes into
an abnormal Rhythm which basically
leaves you pulseless so everybody should
be certified to do CPR yes right you
know the assistant athletic trainer to
be the one and jump in there and get the
job done yeah like that says a lot about
him and that was big because that saved
his life what happens in CPR is you're
squeezing the heart through the outside
of the chest by putting the pressure in
two inches deep and then you're actually
moving the blood in the body as if the
heart was beating and the blood does not
get re-oxygenated but there is some
oxygen still left in the blood so you're
circulating that blood extending the
time to get the defibrillator the
medical assistance all of these tools
that can be used to bring this person
back so CPR absolutely saved us life
here will he play again speculation even
the condition that I was talking about
the doctor start he was having that's
one level of speculation and maybe we
can get there because we can watch the
mechanism but not being his doctor not
knowing the full medical history that's
not even right for me to say on the
catch by the rookie
please
oh my goodness it's scary watching a hit
with the crown of the head obviously for
the player receiving the hit but also
the player delivering the hit because
you're putting a major compressive Force
onto your spine remember there are bones
there but then there's also soft discs
that cushion The Paddock the gravity and
the Bones from rubbing on each other and
those can pop those can go and start
putting pressure on your actual spinal
cords Miller and Allen
and Talib then comes over
oh oh he did that on purpose man that's
Savage I forget that play you know yeah
there's a lot of dirty plays there's a
lot of things that happen in that pile
you know yeah I've heard of pinching and
hair pulling grabbing nuts really all
that type of all the time but it's funny
you're telling me about this Brotherhood
you guys respect each other not
everybody respect their Brotherhood and
then you guys are stabbing not everybody
respect the Brotherhood you got to kick
that person out the Brotherhood remember
this oh yeah my deltoids not my deltoid
it's freaking turf
[Applause]
so there's been a lot of players
complaining about this Turf right even
this year you had guys go down with
non-contact injuries it's it's really
ruined in careers that was pretty much
the last of me I got I felt like I could
have played a couple more years you know
but that play was over because it did
you ever took forever no I just snapped
my deltoids I just cut it out that's
right it's that's usually one of the
strongest that's right and it usually
breaks off bonus that's right yeah so
we've been talking about it all day
right you know the athlete way the
athletes approach there's a lot of
people right now that are Googling how
to get in shape how to eat better I just
find that you know we're the healthiest
people on the planet so being able to
take the way we train the way we sleep
the way we approach our mental Fitness
and put it into one Platform One app and
give that to people it's it keeps me
online when it comes to my life's work
and my purpose a lot of people just need
to lean into the fundamentals so we can
decrease these and outside of the big
injuries it's also just want to feel
better yeah want to perform better yeah
just simple that's it yeah it's not
about just preventing disease and
injuries it's about improving wellness
and enjoyment let's just feel better so
where can people learn more about it you
go to the App Store a search House of
athlete plus see a beautiful little plus
sign right there I need some Plus in my
life let's do it click here to check out
the full interview we just did with
Brandon Marshall he spills all the beans
of Terrell Owens playing in the NFL the
drugs that they actually gave the
players to numb them up really
interesting podcast full interview click
here and as always stay happy and
healthy